this one on the right now i got this one
on the left
now i got this on the right again
and now i got both of them
there you go
hi my name is t moulieu hi i'm aquafina
and i'll be answering fans questions for
lad bible
what is your go-to karaoke song
karaoke song got it i have many i have
many
starting with but not limited to
backstreet boys i want it that way i
want it that way tell me why he ain't
nothing but a ha tell me why you know um
it's easy to get carried away obviously
my go-to karaoke song probably
uh what a fool believes by the doobie
brothers
aladdin i can show you the world
shining shimmering splendid
a whole new world
i'll stop for real this time i'll stop
if you weren't an actor what would you
be doing
oh man i feel like it'd be like a like a
like an ad executive or something like
you know i'm thinking like mad men right
they get to like
take you into these walk into a
boardroom and they're like imagine i
would probably be
um you know one of those people that
kind of
find shells on the beach
i i'm also i think i'm maybe into
pottery
i love a good kiln
where were you when you found out you
were going to be cast in the mcu as the
lead role
i was in my apartment in toronto i was
uh
i was in my underwear
i just woken up from a nap
and i was eating shrimp crackers
by myself and it was uh it was a pretty
incredible moment because i ran around
the apartment in my underwear
i screamed hysterically into my pillow i
may have cried
and
it was a fun time
if you could have the powers and
abilities of any superhero who would it
be
uh the hulk
because i feel like i've been in a
predamon j a couple times and
i just you know i
i you know like they're not seeing me
you know
so i feel like if i hulked it up back
there i'm like i just want to get this
sandwich because it's ready to eat right
wait i mean and i and big fan fred i'm
not dragging you it was it was a busy
day that this one time
what party tricks do you have
um moving my moving my ears
being able to move them separately
this one on the right now i got this one
on the left
now i got this one on the right again
and now i got both of them
there you go
my most impressive party trick would
have to be just
absolutely killing the mood with like a
really depressing statement at the end
of the night um when everybody is like
considering staying like it's like it's
like i would say if like you want one
more white cloud then you just say like
you know um isn't it weird that like
out of all this like um you know we're
all just gonna kind of um be still like
depressed
did you do any of your own stunts in
shanghai and the legend of the ten rings
zero i did absolutely none of my own
stunts and anything more than a brisk
walking pace i uh i flat out refused i
went to my trailer and i said let the
double do it is that a joke that's a
total joke yeah i did i did uh i did
quite a few of my own stunts i mean i
mean you know that's part of the joy of
getting to do movies like this is you
get to
you know be a part of the action and uh
and i definitely wanted to do as much as
i could so
i did do my own stunts and i'm very
proud of them because they mostly
require just to fall backwards
me and gravity you know
do you think pineapple belongs on pizza
i will neither confirm nor deny my
position on that it is it is it is far
too controversial of a question i i'm
literally just starting out at hollywood
okay i can't afford to have my career
jeopardized with questions like this
and in one of these like just high
intense moments i was like
i'll have your babies and he looked down
in my direction and did like his little
paolo nutini smirk and i was
[Music]
like i could die a happy woman